I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired to go to work and come
home every single day fulfilled by the
work that they do. My hope is that this
course takes us a little further down
that path. If people learn their WHY, it
makes them better qualified and more
importantly more confident to choose the
careers, choose the jobs, and find the
companies that create environments in
which they are more likely to be
inspired and feel fulfilled. And that's
the goal. The discovery of WHY was not an
academic exercise or commercial exercise.
It was something deeply, deeply personal.
I had a small business and after a few
years had lost my passion for what I was doing.
People gave me silly advice like
"do what you love." I was doing the same thing,
I didn't love it anymore.
Thanks to the confluence of some events
I discovered this naturally occurring pattern.
I knew what I did and I knew how
I did it but I couldn't tell you why.
And I realized I had to answer that question
if I was gonna find that balance and
so I became obsessed with answering this question,
Why do I do what I do?
Not only did it restore my passion, it restored it
to levels I'd never experienced before.
And as we do when we discover something beautiful
we share it with the people we love.
And so I shared it with my friends and
my friends started making crazy life changes.
And they invited me to share it
with their friends and I would show up
at someone's apartment and literally
give a little talk about this discovery I'd made.
And I would just get more and more
invitations and this thing just
sort of spread organically and its
really changed the course of my life and
changed the course of my career where
now I'm completely devoted to spreading
this idea and helping people either find
their passion or amplify it if they already have it.
Having a job we love is a right
and not a privilege.
It's not for the chosen few.
And so my hope is to share
this idea with as many people as possible
so that indeed saying "I love my
job" becomes the standard and not the exception.
I used to do the WHY Discoveries myself
that's how it began.
I would actually help my friends
learn their WHY. I used to sit down with them
and go through this process, it took
hours, where I'd ask them all about their
life and try and see the patterns to try
and discern their WHY. And it was great
and highly effective but I was the only one
doing it, so I shared it with others
and there was a few of us doing it
but still, you know,
there was this desire to do it
with more people and so we took this process
that I used to do manually and
took everything that I learned and put
it in this online course but it's
basically the exact same thing I used to
do by myself so it's it's really fun to see
it come to life in a course.
The best thing about the WHY is that
it's a biological constant, it has nothing to do
with what we do. It's based on the
biology of how we make decisions and
what drives us and motivates us,
which means that it doesn't matter whether
you're retired or whether you're a
student, it doesn't matter what industry you're in.
This course is designed to
help people understand what makes them tick
and what drives them, what inspires them,
And that's why I'm really proud of this.
I mean this will give people something
to grasp on to and find inspiration
and fulfillment and in everything they do,
hopefully for the rest of their lives.
All you need to do is
have the will and the desire to want
to understand what drives and inspires you.
And that's why we designed this course.
It's designed for people to find that thing,
to understand the thing that
gives them their true north
and helps them wake up every single morning
inspired and come home fulfilled,
I mean, who wouldn't want that?